Hi.
My name is Reto Meier and I'm
the tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations team.
In this Efficient Data Transfers
DevByte, I'm going
to demonstrate a couple of quick
techniques that you can
use to better understand when
your application is making
network requests.
The aim is to modify the data
transfer profile of your apps
to optimize for minimizing the
battery drain caused by
activating the cell radio.
As you may have already seen in
my DevByte on understanding
the cell radio, it's good
practice to use the big cookie
approach to data transfers to
avoid a fragmented network
traffic profile that keeps
the cell radio powered up
indefinitely, in favor of
minimizing the number of radio
state transitions.
And before you optimize your
code, you need a way to
generate these graphs that show
exactly when your app is
transferring data and to
understand what you're looking
for so you can look for areas
that need improvement.
There are several tools
you can use for this.
Most simply, you can use logcat
to generate log entries
that define the timing
information of your network
requests at their start and end
points, and then use the
exported log file to graph the
output using the graphing tool
of your choice.
If you'd like someone to handle
that graphing step for
you, AT&T offer the open source
Application Resource
Optimizer, or ARO tool, that
will generate the pretty
graphs and even overlay the
battery state model, as well
as providing you with specific
recommendations based on their
analysis of your app.
Another great alternative is to
use the Network Statistics
tab in the DDMS view,
which is part of the
Android Developer Tools.
As you can see in this
screenshot, it displays the
amount of data being transferred
and the direction
of the data flow.
Additionally, you can tag your
output sockets to color-code
your data transfers, making it
easier for you to see where
each transfer is originating.
If you're using the HTTP
client to execute your
transfers, the ThreadStatsTag
associated with the current
thread will automatically be
associated with the socket
used for transfers using
the HTTP client.
Note that for socket tagging
to work, you need a device
running Jelly Bean or higher.
So once you've generated a
representation of your app's
transfer profile, you can start
analyzing it for battery
inefficiencies.
The most important thing
to look for are
any periodic transfers.
Any regular pattern of repeating
transfers will cause
a correspondingly regular
pattern of radio activations,
so you're effectively
setting the minimum
level of battery drain.
So the shorter the period
between updates, the higher
the battery drain.
Now in this example, the period
is 15 seconds, more
than enough to keep the
battery powered up
indefinitely.
But depending on the device
and carrier, even a period
over a minute may be enough to
prevent the radio from ever
dropping into standby
mode completely.
Now, we can incrementally reduce
the battery pack by
lowering the frequency of
these regular transfers.
But a better approach is to
try and eliminate periodic
updates completely, allowing
your app to have a baseline of
no battery drain.
Now, periodic data transfer
spikes are typically an
indicator of either a regularly
scheduled upload,
such as analytics or ad
impressions, or client-side
scheduled polling, generally
implemented using it a timer
or a repeating alarm.
You can eliminate both using
some simple best practices.
Anything that's not
time-sensitive, such as
analytics data, ad impressions,
or anything else
that doesn't have a direct
impact on the user experience
should be cued up and batched
to be transferred
together as a group.
The best approach is to simply
fill the queue and trigger all
these delay-tolerant downloads
the next time you need to
perform something that is
time-sensitive, like
downloading new music, updated
headlines, current sports
scores, whatever data your users
are interacting with.
If time-insensitive data is the
only data you transfer,
you may find it necessary to
schedule a daily sync.
In that scenario, the best
approach is to use a
SyncAdapter to handle
this for you.
We'll cover that in
another DevByte.
But where a repeating alarm is
the only thing that will work,
you can try and optimize that by
randomizing the periodicity
as shown here and make the
frequency as low as possible.
If you're polling your server
to check for updates, you
should do everything in your
power to replace client-side
polling with Google
Cloud Messaging.
This technology lets you send
messages from your server to
specific application instances
through Google's Cloud
Messaging infrastructure.
So instead of having each device
poll your server every
1, 5, 15, or 60 minutes to check
for updates which may or
may not exist, you can have your
server notify each device
when there's new information
ready for it to download.
The result is an improved user
experience thanks to both
better battery efficiency and
lower latency updates.
I examine both SyncAdapters and
Google Cloud Messaging in
more detail, as well as
exploring some other
approaches to eliminating
repeating transfers, later in
this DevByte series.
For now, having eliminated
periodic transfers, let's look
at some more indicators for
potential efficiency
improvements.
Another pattern to look for is
short spikes, either in height
or duration.
While they may not be regular,
they typically indicate
transfers that could be bundled
together in the same
way as periodic transfers or
possibly batched together or
even pre-fetched.
The same thing goes for
transfers of any kind that
happen in close proximity
but don't quite overlap.
Now, it's significantly more
efficient to have transfers
happen when the radio is already
in it's active state,
so when a time-sensitive
transfer is initiated for
whatever reason you should look
to preempt any transfers
which are likely to occur within
the next few minutes.
This is particularly true of any
scheduled transfers, but
also includes potentially
user-initiated transfers.
Now for example, say you
have a news app.
If you're forced to perform a
download to let the user read
a full article that you haven't
yet pre-fetched, you
should use this as an
opportunity pre-fetch other
articles that they're likely to
read next, particularly if
switching between your articles
is as simple as
swiping left or right.
Now alternatively, if the action
is time-sensitive but
not critical, for example
uploading an image, it might
be worth holding off for up to
30 seconds, just in case
another transfer is initiated
in the interim.
Now perhaps not surprisingly,
this functionality is built
into the SyncAdapter, which also
handles things like loss
connectivity and batching
transfers across applications.
So it makes it a great approach
for handling all of
your data transfers.
I'll dive into that and
further efficient data
transfer topics in more detail
in other DevBytes in this
series, including how to
implement some of those best
practices using simple code
patterns, Google Cloud
Messaging, and the SyncAdapter.